so I I want to start everything with
just a one-minute clip written by our
from the HBO show Treme so yeah let's do
that
cool hopefully the volume somebody's
gotta call these [ __ ] out he's
running for City Council chuckle real
sign of great political dynasty reason
and that [ __ ] is funny
he's farms from pot to pot satire it's
good to have a chance for his superiors
Orson said woman's
and here we had some serious challenges
we've got the talent expropriation in
people's homes when they're gonna reopen
Charity Hospital this big nasty parched
about who come home you can't go home
here's an idea why are we beating my
campaign
the way I can do exactly the kill this
is real and effective public exposure
some organizations on the table
kick it up a notch okay all right great
so that scene written by our guest
author Tom Piazza gives you just just I
think thank you
gives you just the the smallest sense of
his talent his ability to capture human
ambition making something out of nothing
small but stinging disappointment and
the familiar strangeness of racial
politics in the broadest sense of the
term it's also really funny and
appropriately delightfully drops the
f-bomb okay so so I'll rewind now a
little bit and thank you all so much for
being here I have a more formal version
of that thank you
so let me read it the Frankie seminars
and lectures are intended to present
important topics in the humanities to a
wide and general audience and to tie
interdisciplinary undergraduate
education to the work of distinguished
visiting scholars endowed by Richard and
Barbara Frankie in 2004 the series is
organized each year in conjunction with
an undergraduate seminar taught by a
Yale faculty member or Yale faculty
members and develops the theme of broad
interest in the community the seminars
from an important component of the
humanities curriculum and we are
grateful for the extraordinary support
that the Frankie's continued to provide
for these occasions so thank you to them
and thank you to all of you for being
here mr. Piazza is the author of an
astonishing twelve books including the
novel's a free state my cold war and
city of refuge along with devil sent the
rain music and writing in desperate
times why New Orleans matters and blues
in trouble twelve short stories City of
Refuge one the Willie Morris Award for
southern fiction and his my cold war won
the Faulkner Society Award why New
Orleans matter
I received the Louisiana Endowment for
the Humanities book of the Year award
and blues in trouble won the James
McNair award Piazza is originally
deservedly decorated author add to this
a Grammy mr. Piazza received a Grammy
for his album notes to martin scorsees
Martin Scorsese presents the Blues a
musical journey indeed mr. Piazza has
been a longtime preeminent writer of
American music notably jazz blues
bluegrass and country these writings as
freestanding books as articles in the
New York Times the Atlantic and
everywhere else are part of larger
anthologies have earned him a whole
other chest of awards and of course he
was a principal writer for the HBO
series Treme mr. Piazza went to Williams
College received an MFA in fiction from
the world-renowned Iowa Writers Workshop
and he has been a writer in residence at
several colleges and universities
including Hobart and William Smith
Colleges and late Loyola University for
the seminar that I teach with crystal
teamster New Orleans in the American
imaginary we've read Piazza city of
refuge wine New Orleans matters and his
short story Brownsville and we had a
really wonderful conversation with him
before you all got here so you're late
but it was great so here's the the the
tiniest sliver of what memorizes and
mesmerizes and moved us Piazza conjures
orbs of feeling in words that captivate
completely even or especially as they
unsettle us his words his characters his
narratives stunned in their exposure of
anguish rage disorientation and those
other emotions so hard to sit with but
so necessary to read with in City of
Refuge drawing on metaphors of the body
and human sensoria piazzas New Orleans
is our friend our lover we are nearly
two cities widowed and we come to love
long for and root for the city as we do
the two families black and white who
improvise their way to liveable lives
after the storm and their grotesque
failures of government that followed at
every level and while some of the
connective tissue across our our classes
Piazza's readings as assembles loss
suffering and the resuscitating of
selves and communities alongside
against atmospheric despair anxiety and
disposability I want to also say Piazza
can be really really funny
I found myself snorting and so in Latin
loud socially unacceptable laughter I
Jenna on Qi a beyond raunchy one-liners
in City of Refuge and aunt Mimi is in
Desiree's reposts in Treme I'll hand
over the mic with words from our author
in Y New Orleans matters
Piazza responsed the question so often
asked in fall 2005 usually posed
rhetorically with but the finished veil
to cloak its racism why should we why
should we rebuild New Orleans his answer
is the right one not only for the city
but also for all cities for
infrastructures for knowledge production
for human invention my answer he offers
began with the notion that no city we
know of would exist in its current form
or any other form if it weren't for
human efforts everything worthwhile that
humankind is achieved involves a
rearguard action against entropy without
continual effort it would all quickly
revert to weeds and waste anyone who
owns a house tens of garden raises
children
shaves or does just about anything else
knows this to be true we are always in
this sense pushing back against nature
please welcome Tom Piazza
[Applause]
well thank you Joe do you want your
phone if I speak in a normal voice like
this you all can hear me yeah good thank
you thank you very much for coming out
and I'm so happy to make so many new
acquaintances and to see some old
friends old and dear friends what a
lovely occasion that says thank you and
I want to thank excuse me I want to
especially thank Joe official and
Krystal Fenster or making this all
happen in such a graceful and gracious
way and my Kikaider was indispensable
and incredibly helpful and so thank you
so much to those three and also to the
generosity of Richard and Barbara
Frankie and thanks also to the Whitney
Humanities Center for hosting this so
the title of this talk I guess you've
seen the title of the talk when I was
advertised is improvising identity New
Orleans and the American Dream and I
have to apologize in advance for
delivering a lecture on improvisation
from a prepared written text it's sorry
about that but anyway we'll leave time
for discussion at the end hopefully okay
so let me say that I deliver this
lecture with a degree of trepidation I'm
a novelist not a cultural historian or
ethnographer or not Apple emesis
certainly or even really an essayist as
a novelist I work in an arena in which
opposites are almost always
simultaneously true and in which the
truth such as it is can't be formulated
in discursive terms so I always feel a
degree of discomfort with discourse that
is aiming toward a certain point because
I always almost you know as a trope like
I've tacked in the opposite direction
almost immediately
I want to say that the United States
like New Orleans contains staggering and
often seemingly indigestible
contradictions as soon as you say one
thing about the nature of New Orleans
culture much less American culture it
seems that the opposite is true as well
I would say that both cultures not only
contain but are defined by the fact of
their massive internal contradictions
which fact is almost impossible to
engage head on without getting overrun
by an armada of exceptions
qualifications counter-examples
equivocations mitigations heavy
theoretical artillery and sniper fire
outright evidence to the contrary briefs
for both defense and prosecution instead
in other words of trying to offer a
sustained argument leading to a grand
point what I will offer instead is a
series of patrols into or raids upon a
territory of questions with no clear
answers at the heart of which lies a
paradox that has vexed me from my entire
working life as a writer and as a
citizen how is it possible for a nation
is diverse as maddeningly contradictory
as the United States to consider itself
a single entity a nation with a name
how can its kaleidoscopic ly diverse
elements be recognizably American each
in themselves and yet lend themselves to
a term American that is definable only
in terms of the tension among these
elements even the nation's motto a
pluribus unum from many one can be read
in opposite ways like one of those
ambiguous optical illusions by putting
the weight of meaning either on the many
or on the one and neither of those
readings is really wholly true only the
tension between the two readings stop me
if I'm getting too abstract forget to
whatever soap looks at the point is that
these raids that I'm going to conduct
are plainly gonna be conducted over Swan
ground and sometimes covering the same
track from different angles I've found
hints of a way of understanding this
paradox in New Orleans where I've lived
for 24 years swampy ground if ever there
were swampy ground
if this 40-minute guerilla war that I'm
going to engage in for you here has
anything like a theme it might be that
New Orleans should be seen as a
representative part of the American
tradition of self reinvention
transformation and possibility but I'm
getting ahead of myself
let me begin on the more or less solid
ground of my own experience New Orleans
is a place that I loved in my
imagination from a very young age when I
was 11 years old on Long Island's South
Shore many South Shore people here know
Long Island people here oh okay that's
it
oh no I'll continue all continue so all
right on the South Shore of Long Island
it's sort of act suburbia Burger King's
and gas stations right where I was
raised my mother bought me a copy of a
book called jasmine originally published
in 1939 and reissued in a bright orange
harvest books edition I'd been
interested in musical performance since
the Beatles came to the u.s. in early
1964 when I was 8 and like many others I
followed a trail of recordings and
crumbs from the Beatles to Chuck Berry
to Muddy Waters to Robert Johnson and I
think my mom figured it was a short hop
from there to jazz in any case jasmine
that book is a romantic de Picture
depiction of jazz's early years earliest
years a collection of had Geographic
essays on early jazz musicians such as
King Oliver Bix Beiderbecke and Louis
Armstrong their working lives and
recordings and travels it contains a
fantastic essay on collecting old 78
records in dusty antique stores in dirt
road towns and most important to me a
thick section of photographs in the
middle the grainy black and white images
take
back in the 1910s and 1920s were
mesmerizing bands led by men with names
like Buddy Bolden and bunk Johnson kid
ory dressed in suits or band uniforms
holding trumpets and clarinets and
trombones and banjos these musicians
were black and white although only
rarely did white and black musicians
appear in the same photographs
regardless of skin color they gazed into
the camera through the camera straight
into posterity clearly sure of their own
Worth and place in the world there were
photos of buildings too archaic looking
dance halls and saloons and the
occasional brothel with names like Luth
Jen's and Tom Anderson's and big 25 and
mahogany Hall streets full of light and
shadow with names that were in
themselves a poetry rampart perdido burg
well burgundy which we pronounced as
Burgundy some even named for the Greek
muses Italia Euterpe terpsichore
Calliope which in New Orleans you
pronounce Calliope by the way my
grandparents on either side both sides
had come to America in the late nineteen
teens through Ellis Island eyes firmly
locked on the American Dream and yet
never quite able to let go of the
umbilicus connecting them to the literal
and figurative old country they presided
over long Sunday dinners with aunts and
uncles recycling ancient resentments and
gossip and had endless conversations
about this or that other cousin or uncle
or neighborhood
speaking Italian about half the time yet
at the same time that they held on to
these ancient grudges and secret
handshakes they encourage their children
my father's generation to assimilate and
lay claim to the possibilities afforded
by this new country their bookshelves
held inexpensive matched reprint sets of
Hemingway Steinbeck and Mark Twain as
well as the 20 volumes of the book of
knowledge with their imposing embossed
oxblood colored faux leather
the children not just of the Italians
but the Irish and the Polish Catholics
in the Eastern European Jews took the
queue and moved out after World War two
some of them anyway from Brooklyn and
Queens to the Long Island post-war
suburbs where every immigrant could have
the same house and bleach their ethnic
complexion to the roughly the same hue
that seemed to be the idea anyway so
Long Island's South Shore where my
parents settled with its endless
stretches of department stores and
Levittown inspired tract housing
developments its yawning sky as yet
uninterrupted by big trees or
interesting looking buildings
represented an aggressively asserted
version of normalcy after the
unimaginable sacrifices and hardships
and heartbreaks of the Second World War
a promised land for many of those who
had lived through it black and white
although obviously coming down more
heavily on the white side but it was an
eerily affectless and rootless landscape
to a generation of adolescents who came
of age there myself included those
photos and Jasmine became for me a kind
of treasure map a set of clues to what
might be possible in life a taproot into
a past that could nourish the present
and future in ways I could not yet
imagine but which I could feel like the
tangy air of coming springtime - this is
the second raid this is a series of
raids New Orleans is often characterized
as a special case kind of place within
the United States we talked about this a
bit Joe and and crystal and I somehow
not entirely American partly European
partly Caribbean Caribbean divorced or
at least amicably separated from the
supposed American ethos of hard work
rugged individualism and capitalist
venality this is not entirely inaccurate
but it is most certainly incomplete at
best
New Orleans is in my view a
quintessentially American place one
which reflects and embodies that
tensions and irony's the survival
strategies and the as-yet unhealed and
inadequately addressed wounds of the
nation as a whole new orleans with its
exposed roots in France in Spain in
Africa has offered a model not of
cultural assimilation that mythic and
monstrous melting pot that we all hear
about but rather a cultural policy the
city is fashioned a collective identity
out of Constituent national and ethnic
identities French Italian African
Spanish German Irish the list is too
long to continue the food the music the
architecture our famously amalgams of
all the distinct identifiable ethnic
components and yet also unmistakably New
Orleans this construction of what might
be called a cultural identity out of the
tension among wildly various
pre-existing cultural identities is
nothing if not a paradox generating an
endless series of complications and
variations Moray patterns that summon a
reality far more complex and richly
textured than any of their component
parts and I think much the same thing
might be said about the country as a
whole
3 America has never quite settled for
itself where it stands in relation to
the question of inherited position of
whatever variety versus social and
cultural mobility the nation as a whole
and New Orleans in particular afford the
freedom and sometimes the necessity of
switching identities assuming
alternative identities at the same time
they advance a counterbalancing emphasis
on the centrality and dominance of old
families and other types of lineage on
the one hand the injunction to recreate
yourself expand your horizons go west
innovate on the other a sharply
articulated awareness of family
background class privilege ethnicity
race gender identify errs this emphasis
is asserted the more strongly in
proportion to the social flaw
amid which it exists and it can be found
across the class and ethnic spectrum the
DAR Mayflower descendants the Social
Register the old-line families of New
Orleans of Boston
of every major city as well as all the
urgent identifiers involved in what is
usually referred to as identity politics
and the abrupt rise and hunger for DNA
evidence of genetic background
ancestry.com should really be called
identity dot-com now does anybody know
the story Nathaniel Hawthorne's story my
kinsmen major Molyneux a Molino that one
ah Greg got to turn you on to a good
story Nathaniel Hawthorne's short story
my kinsmen major Molyneux oh man you got
readers it's it's one of the great
American story follows a young man from
the countryside named Robin as he
arrives in a certain little metropolis
of a New England colony in search of a
supposedly wealthy relative who's gonna
set him up kind of install him in a
position and endow him with privilege
that he hasn't earned himself he hasn't
he's very young he hasn't had a chance
to earn this position but he thinks this
kinsman of his is going to hook him up
this is all fine with our young man but
as he walks the streets inquiring as to
where he might find his kinsman major
MOA no he's met with hostility and
ridicule until finally a wise and
helpful spirit invites Robin to wait
with him on the street with the promise
that Robins kinsmen will soon pass by
and he does the major does born on a
litter by a wild mob got up in crazy
garb with faces painted with wild music
by torchlight and he's been tarred and
feathered as the joke sinks in for Robin
the folly of leaning too heavily on the
expectation that his antecedents his
inherited identity will make his way for
him instead of having to create it for
himself his wise companion and joins him
not to leave and go back to the country
but to remain in town where he quote may
rise in the world without the help of
your kinsmen major mo no remake yourself
lived with the joke sustained tension
between the hand you were dealt and what
you make of it
improvisation is the word for making
your own variations upon a set of Givens
and America has been an improvisers
culture nothing if not an improvisers
culture the nation grew out of the need
to use and transform what was to be
found here in a landscape not just
geographical but social and economic and
the culture advances this myth of
improvisation and countless ways from
the comic to the tragic end of the
spectrum the leaving of home in search
of a dream an elusive prize that often
turns out not to be worth it or an
illusion as in Bobby bear's great
performance of the song Detroit City
anybody know that song look at you guys
ok I hope you all are taking notes you
need to go check this stuff out Detroit
City is great with this song that song
in the persona of a guy who has left his
home down south and goes up north to
work in the factories in Detroit he says
bye-bye day I make the cars by night I
make the bars Hey okay and then there's
this refrain and it uh I want to go home
oh gee but I wanna go home
thank you anyway but you know that
refrain of I want to go home lives
underneath American song and literature
consistently as it became more and more
American chorus underneath all the
restless traveling and optimistic
bluster there as an ostinato of sorts
the voyage maybe the traveling north
from a South Shore town opportunity or
the leaving of the East with its
establishment norms heading for the
frontier of the West with all of its
possibilities and its dangers
or it could be Nick Carraway leaving the
Midwest for New York with all of its own
Gatsby s promises and dangers the old
paradigm so often to be found in
European novel certainly of the
provincial coming to the city to make
his way upward literally and
figuratively
a novel saved from an excessive reliance
on the European model by the resounding
ly symbolic invention of Gatsby with his
insatiable hunger our two greatest
American novels contain multitudes
Huckleberry Finn of course with its
improvising protagonist who just wanted
to go somewhere he warn't particular and
his encounter with the grand array of
riverfront con men and masqueraders in
the company of Jim an enslaved person
who was making his own gamble on freedom
and whose fate is inextricably bound up
with hugs and then there's Moby Dick
with its Pequod populated by every
imaginable nationality and ethnic group
presided over by Ahab and his
monomaniacal quest for something
unattainable domination over nature of
her life itself a mania that leads to
doom in Twain's book everything turns
out okay and in Melville's book
everything ends in shards and splinters
which vision prevails we hang suspended
between both for the novelist Ralph
Ellison once remarked that the search
for identity is the American theme he
gave that search a form in his novel
Invisible Man
which we talked about today in class in
which the narrator and central character
lacks a name as well as a fixed identity
excuse me and is constantly looking to
other people and external situations to
lend him one and yet the word search
feels problematic to me with its
implicit positioning of identity as a
fixed goal something findable
pre-existing awaiting discovery the
novel's protagonist never does disembark
at some safe harbor of a found or even a
constructed identity after all only
calls a supposedly temporal temporary
truce with that goal as if on the next
try he might emerge from his underground
hole and finally grasp it create the
uncreated feature
of his face in his twist on Stephen
Dedalus desire to create the uncreated
conscience of his race but perhaps the
idea of that search itself is not just
elusive but a mistake an error in
perception
perhaps identity in the American sense
the broadest American sense involves not
so much the search for must much less
the discovery of the single pre-existing
role of waiting one some final secured
off-the-rack identity or even the
creation of a single definitive face for
oneself as it does the constant
transformation of the given the
conversion of objects into subjects the
act of creative argument with one's own
assumptions and I would say that
identity is to be located in the nature
and quality of that transformation that
conversion that argument a dynamic
engagement with it all a kind of
hologram created by energies pointed in
different directions in an essay on Bob
Dylan who's I think is one of the most
representative American artists who's
ever done it in my collection devil sent
the rain I said I wasn't an essayist but
it's an essay collection it's also got
some journalism in it examining the
extraordinary variety of American
utterance and reference to which Dylan
laid and lays still claim I tripped on
the word American and the word America a
couple times and I wrote this America
meaning what again cowboys and Indians
New York City Hollywood the Civil War
the CIA interstate highways Main Street
Walmart John Wayne John Wayne Gacy Earl
Scruggs Muhammad Ali Rosa Parks Don
Rickles Flaco Jimenez Edmund Wilson
redwood forests Gulf Stream waters Ellis
Island Los Alamos America wants to
include all possibility hence
takes up potentially all the space there
is it expands something so internally
contradictory is of course a target for
every kind of projection the mind has
trouble accepting such intense
contradictions within the same entity
their presence creates a profound
anxiety learning to accept them as a
discipline to identify with the culture
itself means identifying with a high
level of tension among elements it means
identifying with the tension itself five
hmm it's gonna be a long lecture five in
the birth of tragedy Friedrich Nietzsche
sets out his famous notion of what he
calls the Apollonian and Dionysian
aspects of human nature positing a
fruitful tension between them roughly
and somewhat over simply put the
Apollonian tendencies are those that
pull in the direction of order measure
hierarchy and individuation and the
Dionysian or Dionysian aspects represent
the tendency toward dissolution of a
distinct self in communal orgiastic
activity and altered states that exist
to use his phrase beyond good and evil
on one side morals ethics moderation on
the other impulse excess unregulated
passion he also states if I read him
correctly that the two sets of impulses
exist in a kind of corrective
relationship one to the other American
culture has always struggled to maintain
its balance on this fault line like a
tightrope walker constantly making micro
and sometimes macro corrections if any
single place in the United States
distills the essence of the contrast and
tension between the Apollonia and the
Dionysian it would be New Orleans and
never more fully than at Mardi Gras time
when the entire community almost
participates in both the Dionysian
loosening of moral ligature in masking
drinking eating and doing all the other
stuff we know about at the same time the
Apollonian reenactments of traditions
and pageantry that go back well into the
19th century and really been some cases
before that often in detail scripted
down to the smallest hand gesture
literally whether we see bank presidents
who wear hoods unhappily reminiscent of
Klan outfits riding on lavishly
decorated floats in the crew of wrecks
the always white king of Carnival or the
grand mirroring mockery of the 100-plus
year old African American social club
Zulu with its own King and court
consisting primarily of the city's black
bourgeois elite dressed in parody bitter
parody of supposedly African garb grass
skirts and blackened faces or the Mardi
Gras Indians made up primarily of
working-class African Americans who roam
the streets wearing extraordinary
handmade suits and singing songs and
performing ritualized gestures that go
back again well into the 19th century is
the mask that endowed the individual
with the ability to transcend the given
and emerge into the possibility of
transformation in either case this
transformation is sanctioned understood
as a necessary element in managing and
mediating energies that might otherwise
break loose and do lasting damage to the
social order this dissolution of the
day-to-day self or rather this
substitution of another self that
exempts one from the usual
responsibilities and guidelines of
social standing propriety station
location affiliation is understood by
all concern to be an assumed identity a
mask that transforms you six while all
this is recognizable as
characteristically New Orleans we should
also understand that masking is not just
a perennial but a defining element of
American culture as a whole it's of
course true that masking is part of the
cultural fabric in most places in the
world in ritual enactment and
celebration but it has served important
additional purposes here in our
mythology drenched cultural landscape
we're social position excuse me ethnic
background gender identity even the mass
appetite for team sports may be
understood as a form of masking a shadow
play of identity it has been a way of
encoding or channeling aspiration doubt
guilt even unspeakable desire and as
often in itself served as a passport to
social mobility members of marginalized
groups have often found it necessary or
desirable to become virtuosos of the
mask whether Jewish Americans who have
passed for Gentiles or African Americans
with skin light enough to allow them to
quote pass for white in both cases as a
way of opening doors of opportunity for
themselves and their families that might
otherwise have remained closed the
masquerade can go both ways
of course the foundation of a
recognizable indigenous American musical
performance was blackface minstrelsy
the most peculiar institution of
American culture in the 19th century and
well into the 20th B it said the rock
and roll of its time in fact white
performers blackened their faces with
burnt cork and perform stylized and
often as I said this in class viciously
caricatured impressions of supposed
black types whether devious or carefree
and scenes of idyllic life on the old
plantation this entertainment found its
first mass audience in the north where
the scenes of blacks portrayed is either
simple-minded or criminal eased the
collective white mind somewhat about
being complicit in the perpetuation of
slavery it would be nearly impossible to
overstate minstrel seized influence on
the course of American popular
entertainment Sam Phillips the
charismatic founder of the legendary
Memphis record label record company Sun
Records said sometime around 1954 1955
find me a white man who can sing like a
Negro and I'll make a million dollars
and when he discovered Elvis Presley he
made his million and more and more
but 100 years before that white men
singing supposedly like Negroes
dominated the entertainment world the
assuming of the mask of blackness
endures today in every white suburban
high school kid who imitates the
gestures and accents of rappers holy
that mask of blackness allowing the
expression of attitudes and modes of
expression otherwise considered
unacceptable and so-called proper ie
white society but blackface blackface
performance was not the only form of
ethnic masking that became wildly
popular in the u.s. far from it the
early 20th century with its mass influx
of immigrants from Southern and Eastern
Europe was a rich time for ethnic
impersonation vaudeville drew upon a
gallery of stock characters based on
ethnic stereotypes and in fact provided
an entrance ramp from which so many
German Irish Jewish immigrants made
their way into the American
entertainment mainstream like cars
entering a fast-moving interstate Jewish
performers especially have been ballet
masters of this kind of masking often
this entree actually came from carrying
on the minstrel tradition as the singer
Al Jolson did in full blackface singing
songs like mammy both on stage and in
the first popular talking picture the
jazz singer released in 1927 songwriter
Irving Berlin who was Jewish providing a
mostly Christian nation with its holiday
anthem white Christmas all the way to
Bob Dylan born Robert Zimmerman Bob
Dylan's appropriation of everything he
liked from ancient Anglo Irish ballads
through country blues rock and roll
lyric poetry and more Saul Bellow once
remarked that you are entitled to steal
anything in writing that you are strong
enough to carry out freedom suggests
itself as the readiness to adopt as many
masks as possible 7 New Orleans has been
called the land of dreams and songs like
Basin Street Blues and Way Down Yonder
and New Orleans but has anyone ever
defined that much abused formulation the
American dream a thing devoutly to be
wish'd apparently a protein set of
possibilities that everyone defines for
himself or herself out of what an uneasy
sleep such a dream might come in any
organized social context one leads a
double life at least as both a private
individual and a member of the society
in the United States each individual
carries the weight of responsibility for
the fate of the Democratic Enterprise
itself this noble flawed experiment in
which we were engaged Huckleberry Finn
tries to escape it for most of a novel
but is finally forced into assuming
responsibility for his choice regarding
the fate of his friend the escaped slave
Jim in Moby Dick the men on the Pequod
maintained their varied individual
aspects while performing their duties as
seamen their limited responsibility for
the collective enterprise as that
enterprise is hijacked by the unstable
genius Captain Ahab a commander-in-chief
driven by revenge walking the deck alone
at all hours accepting no counsel
tweeting from his cabin in the middle of
the night sorry I got my commanders
mixed up for a moment to me New Orleans
is the American Dream writ large in
dayglo colors and it takes the word
dream literally in that it advances in
symbolic form images meant to embody not
just possibilities hidden yearnings
hungers and needs but also warnings of
danger perhaps too deep and threatening
to face straight on what could be more
dreamlike more symbolic and more
troublingly American than the uproar
around the removal of the stone effigies
of Jefferson Davis and robert e lee from
the perches where they were set up over
a century go ago to remind the citizenry
of a white supremacy that seemed lost
during Reconstruction but that had been
reclaimed quickly by the oh so brave
riding masked in hoods to reassert white
dominance what could be more dreamlike
than individuals from inside and outside
the city watching the removals dressed
in Confederate flag bandanas and yes we
can
t-shirts with Barack Obama's likeness on
them youths and army fatigue jackets
with peace symbols and motorcycle guys
with denim vest carrying automatic
weapons we solve it if you were there
which I was you would think that the
Civil War had never been settled and
that the fate of the Union still hangs
in the balance
and it does it does we've entered a time
now in which the word American has been
hijacked by thieves and suits and flag
lapel pins who assert that America means
white people not people of color
straight nuclear family people not gay
or transgender people certainly not
immigrants while they robbed the country
blind under the cloak of law and order
with a sociopathic six-year-old at the
helm mattered by far than Captain Ahab
attempting to push large groups of
Americans and aspiring Americans to the
margins often by executive orders that
would write them out of the very
definition of American black lives
women's lives lives of the appropriately
named dreamers all of whom find it
necessary to insist as a means of their
very survival on their distinct
identities turning and turning in the
widening gyre the Falcon cannot hear the
falconer Things Fall Apart the center
cannot hold
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
rote Yeats of course in the second
coming and perhaps it is not mere
anarchy but a carefully crafted
shadowplay of mass distraction allowing
a small percentage of vested brigands to
steal the silver and gold in the
introduction to devil sent the rein my
essay collection speaking of
developments during the George W Bush
administration I wrote the following the
divisions that were being wedged more
and more deeply into the National
Dialogue wear cycle
logical even mythological what were once
differences of policy and even
philosophy had become coated with magic
and superstition manipulations cunningly
crafted to bypass the reasoning faculty
and go right to the heart of the fear
and uncertainty that were there under
the crust like rich oil reserves that
could be tapped to fuel a brutal
expansion the question became whether
there was an opposing magic to
counteract the enormous undertow of all
that imagery all that appealed to easy
comforting answers and quote and that
was written about a time ten years ago
and more I made a landscape of discourse
that was downright Athenian compared to
the slop bucket were in now is there a
cure must things fall apart I asked
myself that question after Katrina
revisiting the broken city my home that
I loved and that many wanted to write
off but that needed to be fought for
could New Orleans offer not just a dream
warning for the nation but a dream hint
of a way forward eight I hit my stride
as a fiction writer and maybe as an
improviser on my first trip to New
Orleans in 1987 I had landed in town to
spend a week trying to recover from a
broken heart
and to attend the Jazz and Heritage
Festival which I had wanted to do for
years on arrival I found that my
accommodations were going to be
different than I thought I was either
going to have to share a bed with the
proprietor of the guesthouse that I had
booked eight hide that book sight unseen
from some sketchy advertisement I should
say this is before for those of you
under graduate age this is before the
Internet this was before in our Airbnb
home away Expedia whatever it might be
this was like you looked in like
advertisements and it was like closing
your eyes and throwing a dart really
which though proffered as an option
what I mean sharing the bed with the
proprietor was not one as far as I was
concerned or to sleep on a folding cot
in the kitchen where I had spotted
several cockroaches that resembled
good-sized cigar butts only ambulatory I
took a moment or three to wrap my brain
around the situation this was not the
New Orleans groove that I had imagined
but as if one set of assumptions were
being slid off of me like a decal and
another SID slid into place I thought no
man you want to come to New Orleans this
is what it is this is the hand you've
been dealt deal with it or don't deal
with it and I thought I'll deal with it
so I slept in the kitchen and the next
night a bonafide guest room opened up as
if by magic but for me the project of
writing I'm sorry the process of writing
a novel is very much like this you have
one set of ideas when you embark and a
provisional sense of the map of the book
may be but as you get into it and find
out that certain things are less
possible than you thought they were and
characters reveal aspects of themselves
that you didn't anticipate you have to
go with that you have to improvise a
response to the unforeseen and out of a
series of such responses your book
begins to find its identity I don't know
that all writers work this way but I in
fact I'm sure they don't but I do think
that most literary writers probably do
was it just a total coincidence that I
found my first voice as a fiction writer
on my first visit to New Orleans I don't
know maybe but I sat at the Napoleon
house and wrote the first draft of my
first good short story Brownsville by
the way my first that was the first one
I wrote where I really actually felt
coordinated you know wrote the first
draft of my first short story
Brownsville and in fact when I send it
in to Gordon lish great editor sort of
legendary editor Gordon lish used added
fiction for Esquire and other places
when I sent it in to Gordon licious
magazine the quarterly I sent it in
under a pseudonym and assumed identity
masks if you will I will not tell you
what it is because I might need it again
someday
leave it that I had literally found
another way to be myself if self is even
really the right word but New Orleans
would teach me many more lessons in
years to come some lessons were welcome
and some were no but even the unwelcome
ones proved to be useful as I improvised
my responses and one of the lessons
maybe the most important was that rarely
is anything exactly what it seems on
first glance so let me tell you a little
story about that to close out this
lecture shortly after I arrived in New
Orleans to live which was in 1994 after
years of visiting every chance I could
find I made the acquaintance of a Mardi
Gras Indian chief named Donald Harrison
Big Chief Donald Harrison somebody's
nodding their head Big Chief of the
guardians of the flame tribe can I
reasonably assume that most of you know
what Mardi Gras Indians were by the way
I should ask dude to raise your hand if
you don't know I want to see if you
don't know okay all right don't be
afraid you know ok good everybody knows
terrific so Donald Harrison was the
chief of this particular gang he's also
the father of the wonderful jazz
saxophonist Donald Harrison jr. anyway
so you know the Mardi Gras Indians gangs
of African Americans who spend most of
every year sewing elaborate feathered
costumes that they wear for the first
time on Mardi Gras day and then only a
couple more times afterward and making a
new one the next year and so forth the
tradition goes well back into the 19th
century as I said before their visual
impact is often overwhelming as is the
sound of their chanted songs in rhythmic
accompaniment I wish we had some film
footage to show right now but there's
plenty in Treme for sure I no longer
remember exactly how I met chief Donald
although I had seen him dressed in one
of his astonishing suits assemblages
like all Mardi Gras Indian suits
consisting of feathers and beaded
pictorial patches sewn onto canvas and
jewels and geometric arrangements it
explosions of glorious invention and
grandeur whatever the circumstances I
must have expressed an interest in
talking to him about the Indians and he
with a very characteristic New Orleans
generosity of spirit invited me to meet
him for a drink at a bar in the Treme by
some accounts the oldest continuously
occupied African American neighborhood
in North America in New Orleans just
across the rampart Street from the
French Quarter it's where it begins so I
showed up and waited for him for about
half an hour until through the bars
gloomy half light I saw him approaching
a very different figure from the one I
had last seen decked out in powder blue
plumes and feathers engaged in a verbal
duel with some other Indian chief this
was a trim man and a very natty jacket
and stingy brim porkpie hat he greeted
me and we fell easily into conversation
and this is how I described the
encounter in my book why New Orleans
matters rather than try to strain to
recast it for you I'll just tell you how
it goes I said we chatted for a while
about this and that he asked me what
kind of work I did and I told him I
write books
he asked me what kind and I told him
both fiction and nonfiction and that I
wrote a lot about music as well I asked
him if he liked to read and he told me
he did when I asked him what he liked to
read he said mainly philosophy and some
fiction I have an extensive library of
books on philosophy and african-american
history as well this surprised me I
thought I knew what and who the Mardi
Gras Indians were and I was surprised to
hear this man whom I had seen dressed in
elaborate Indian regalia plumes and
feathers sprouting chanting African
based rhythms / tambourine background
say that he read philosophy to my shame
I had a moment of skepticism that lay
beneath my next question which was which
philosophers do you like to read lately
he said mainly Bertrand Russell but I
loved Nietzsche too it's an old American
situation of course anyone interested in
and essay on the subject should read
Ralph Ellison's the little man at chi-ha
station in his collection going to the
territory or Constance Rourke's seminal
book length study American humor by the
way I want to recommend that book to you
it's dated in some respects it came out
in 1931 Constance work is one of the
most unjustly neglected cultural
historians who's ever done that thing
and her book American humor is
indispensable in fact I learned about it
from Ralph Ellison and his friend Albert
Murray also a Tuskegee educated novelist
and nonfiction writer anyway both of
these books extended meditations on the
masks not just that we put on for others
but that we put on others it's a lesson
that one has to learn continually in New
Orleans it's the end of the quote and I
would add in our lives as Americans
improvising our way through a
continuously evolving landscape of
possibility and identity and I'm going
to leave it there and now I'll improvise
some responses to questions or remarks
if you have any I want to thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
any questions any remarks anything - any
balls - serve me over the net I'll hit
it back if I can okay yes ah the
question for if you couldn't hear it was
what's my connection between jazz and
the act of writing you said yeah well
that's there probably a few different
ways I could answer that and they all
probably go back to the idea of
improvisation although I don't consider
jazz to be strictly an improvisation I
think improvisation is inextricably
bound up with jazz music for me I can
answer maybe in two or three parts for
one thing my notion of the act of the
process of generating a fictional
narrative is is very improv-y to wit I
usually have some kind of provisional
sense when I start out of what the chord
changes will be by the way the person
who asked this question is a dear old
friend of mine who I have not seen for
probably 40 years Bryant or Foose one of
the finest American bass players great
jazz bass player and other genres so
that's where that question comes from so
the chord changes in effect you know one
might have a sense that one's gonna you
know one thinks one's going to start out
playing you know I'll remember April and
you find out you're really playing
Stardust yeah but you have to get into
the text to find that out so the process
of composition entails constantly being
alive to the things that are being
suggested to you by the text that you've
already generated okay so it's improv
the story in that sense and then of
course one has the luxury if one's a
fiction writer going back and rewriting
which of course Sonny Rollins doesn't
have so so it's so there's that second
of all and I guess I'm gonna have to
paraphrase something I was saying in
response to one of the students in the
class this afternoon I
experience the writing of prose in a
musical way and even in a choreographic
way in a sense which is that one is
dealing with the manipulation
that's us I don't like the overtone
series of that particular word but one's
dealing yes with the manipulation of the
passage of time and the nature of
sequence and the fact of sequence which
is every bit as important in writing
fiction as it is in five-card stud poker
where you roll the cards one at a time
you're trying to set up expectations and
then either subvert them or satisfy them
in some kind of surprising and agreeable
way and and coherent way well the same
thing could be said about playing a jazz
solo or playing in a jazz group but
specifically with the sentences and the
progress of paragraphs one is one can
spend you know an entire Ulysses on one
day in Dublin or one can you know also
go through 30 years in a paragraph so
that is the manipulation of time there's
that wonderful there's a great
performance by John Coltrane a jazz fans
in the house people like jazz a couple
to people don't be ashamed to raise your
hands stick up for jazz music well
there's a great recording by John
Coltrane called blue train it's the
title of an album and of a track on the
ends of blues and in it train at certain
Coltrane at certain places would be
playing many many notes over if it's a
walking tempo blues about like this
maybe right about there and sometimes
he's playing melodies ago that's sort of
like bad maybe 32nd notes or whatever
there and then he'll start playing
eighth notes and quarter notes and it's
as if it's again a metaphor I used in
class today but it's as if at a certain
point there's stuff going by a train
window so fast that it's a blur and then
suddenly you come out into open country
and you see a farmhouse whatever so I
can't help that kind of synesthetic
dimension of writing prose narrative
prose specifically
and I find it actually a very tenable
analog to playing jazz does that answer
the question sure who else do I have to
ask myself questions okay go ahead
that's okay
what an interesting question did
everybody hear it basically okay what if
you heard it so I won't try to
recapitulate basically what if the
series were called you know named for
some other neighborhood in New Orleans
how could that even though it takes even
though Treme takes in or many many
different the series addressed itself to
many different places in New Orleans
what if the accent were placed on a
different sulabha
and it were named for a different
neighborhood I think in a way well what
is a title in the first place a title is
some sort of some kind of a God function
doesn't it and that title you know a
title is related to a text the way God
is related to creation and one way at
least which is to say it addresses
itself or sheds light upon looks over
the entire scope of the narrative that
it applies to so in that sense a title
functions almost like a bit of a
creation myth
so you're saying here is the root of
meaning in this text okay so if you were
just title the the series by water right
away you're writing about something now
may take in every neighborhood but
you're saying the wellspring of meaning
is the experience of people who and
institutions that you know come that are
peculiar to this area in this
neighborhood if you were to title it
French Quarter you know that's been done
or if you were to title it anyone you
know lower nine oh pardon me sorry or if
you were to title it you know Gentilly
each one of these titles would suggest
that somehow the experience or the fact
of this particular lineage of experience
is somehow going to cast
light that encompasses everything else
so you'd have a completely different
creation myth in a sense now with Treme
the the net and I did not title the
series and I've never been convinced
that it was necessarily absolutely the
ideal title for the series but whatever
for one thing because people kept asking
me if I wrote for treem you know is that
a soda or what you know anyway but so
whether it was the weather was the ideal
title or not I think what he was saying
being that it was this historically
ancient really african-american
settlement neighborhood within New
Orleans it is saying something about
african-american culture in New Orleans
as being foundational to the city and
fructifying to all the different
narratives in all parts of the city that
maybe an impossibly romantic view of it
but I don't think it's completely off
the wall so anyway so and I think that's
what would change we can't go I don't
wanna go through all the different
possible you know
parameter permutations of but but that's
I think how it would change that's the
nature of how it would change that's an
improvised answer I was all right okay
thanks Joe yeah sure
you know like I wonder like what is
happening is it's a multi-part question
so what are some examples of masking in
the talk
well I think it always in tape masking I
think probably always entails an
injunction to improvising improvise
because you're going to find yourself in
an unaccustomed situation you know I
mean unless it's the same mask you wear
every week you know but even then even
then now of course we find ourselves in
unscripted situations even when we're
not quote-unquote wearing a mask but a
lot of times a mask is put on you I mean
you know we're constantly measuring the
temperature of any situation the slant
of light in a situation how does this
person see me what are the assumptions
this person has I walk into this room as
a person that I have my own
understanding may be provisional of Who
I am I walk in this room is a bunch of
people who are going to have certain
class assumptions about me certain
ethnic assumptions you know so we're
constantly improvising our responses to
these situations one of the things that
masks can do is allow you to control
that a little bit more like okay I
understand what this Frankenstein mask
is going to say to a number of people I
see they're going to see it as a you
know a quotation about a monster movie
it's howling so they can be relating to
the mask while undoing something else
this is one of the great advantages of
masking you know like for instance you
could have a president let's say who was
a complete swindler deadbeat really
mentally deficient you know and and
really out to bilk everybody from every
last dollar that they have if he could
but who presents himself as a great
populist hey you know these guys love oh
yes you know so people who want to see
that mask you can use that mask to
manipulate and steal the silver you know
and we're living through that now in my
opinion but so a mask in other words I
think allows you to control the
circumstances of the improvisation in a
way and maybe to a degree
that you wouldn't be able to if you just
came out as yourself because after all
even our sense of our own selves is very
fragmented most of the time we don't you
know we talk very glibly about who we
are myself this is who I've this is my
identity
your identity is about twelve or
fourteen different things at any given
time anyway you know you're one person I
mean this is a dull thing to say it's so
obvious and said so often but you know
we're different people with our parents
with our fruit lovers whatever so the
nature of improvisation to me is just
presence finally and quality of
alertness to the implications of what is
being dealt you at that time now were
you saying you wanted an example of
masking from the oh all right okay but
does this make sense we're saying does
that adequately address what you were
raising yeah well did you have some yeah
nice word and I just a quote that he has
is that New Orleans is both and rather
than either/or this resonates with your
wake with your clock and I was just
wondering do you think like you might
not be able to answer this question but
my question is what do you think kind of
this source of that identity is in New
Orleans do we think it's just an
accident of history
kind of the fact that in many ways the
oldest people in New Orleans are not the
Americans but the Creoles and they also
some Louisiana the Cajuns the people
from the Caribbean etc and therefore you
know to be the true scene where leaning
is not necessarily to be the truest
American or is it something that has
developed uniquely in subsequent years
what what a question well or yeah it's a
question there are so many things that
are germane to New Orleans history that
where you could say well here's the
historical reason why this kind of thing
developed in this way the and I don't I
don't have enough of the actual factual
history at my fingertips where I could
say well here was the thing when the
Germans settled this neighborhood and so
and so I can't approach the question
from that angle what I can say is that
first and foremost first and foremost
above everything else New Orleans is a
port all right so anytime you have a
port you have an extraordinary
extraordinarily heterogeneous population
that is engaged in a lot of different
kinds of activity some of which is very
opportunistic some of which is you know
exploratory people are leaving people
are coming in who are strangers you've
got all the ingredients of every kind of
story right there the departure on an
adventure on a voyage of discovery the
arrival in town of the stranger you've
got it all mixed together so every all
of these narratives these different
types of narratives are mixing together
in a you know an active port to degree
that they don't let say in the sort of
mythic small town you know in which
there's a certain stasis and then it's
disturbed a little bit by this or that
irregularity of whatever sort so New
Orleans first of all even without
anything else going on is a port and it
has all that kind of implied injunction
to improvisation based on all these
pleas
what is this it has to be there okay hey
how you doing
alright so was I talking about oh yeah
so it's an improvident ori situation to
begin with but especially because of the
first of all it was had this peculiar
double quality of being one of the most
active slave markets that there was
especially for a certain period and at
the same time as having a huge
population of free people of color so
right away you're in you're in a kind of
Hall of Mirrors right away then you had
neighborhoods that were settled
successfully successively by the French
by the Spanish we know this you know
other neighborhoods that were pockets of
Italian you know New York shares some
New York City shares some of that
quality so you have all that mixture of
cultural richness and also mutual
suspicion and and cultural blending all
that stuff that comes from having a very
diverse population in any situation so
all of that is there also and I mean I
could go on and on about this but one of
the other things about New Orleans was
that at specifically African and Africa
are bein but but specifically African
cultural elements were maybe by an
accident of civic law or something
allowed to be expressed publicly in a
way that they weren't in a lot of places
so though many of you have probably
heard of Congo Square which was this
area in New Orleans right on one side of
between I guess between Basin and
rampart Street where enslaved people
could go and play drums African drumming
outside and dance this is back even and
you know the 18th century in the 19th
so what the ethnographers sometimes
called African retentions were just out
there you know in plain sight and were
an animating supremely an animating
dimension of the city's cultural life
you know from from way back and way back
so I guess I'm losing the threat of the
question maybe a little bit but I take
it that you're asking me why is New
Orleans why is New Orleans such a
diverse places I think you know why is
there such an injunction to
improvisation there but I think anytime
that you have all that cultural
historical and whatever you want to say
contrast you're going to have that and
then specifically add to that the port
city dimension and the fact that it was
a French colony for a long time you know
that too
gave this odd this somewhat different
cast many reasons and I suggest if you
want to read an excellent book about New
Orleans history especially the early
part of New Orleans history the Tulane
professor Laurence Powell wrote a book
called the accidental city and that's I
think probably the best history of early
New Orleans that you could that you
could read and if you haven't read it
especially you've been from New Orleans
when I check that out yes to the man in
the blue watch cab
the American Dream writ large with any
[ __ ] up they also their attention
warnings of dangers okay I'll try to do
that in his compact the time are we are
we worried about time is it okay fine
good so when I said it was kind of the
American Dream writ large what I mean by
that is that a broad spectrum of
cultural affiliation is allowed an
extraordinary wide palette upon which to
for each one is able to you have French
Spanish you have all of these ethnic
regional national identifiers really
being out there in full view in full
expression vigorous full expression and
yet also at the same time contributing
to these kind of syncretic forms that
are combinations of these different you
know identifiable ethnic and whatever
else traditions so to me that is sort of
the American dream
for me that that because I think the the
dream which is not necessarily the
reality that God knows all the time is
that we maintain a fruitful tension
between where we came from you know
where what however you might want to
read that and what might be possible for
us whether it's gender transformation
whether it's singing music from a
completely different tradition than ours
as Saul Bellow said whatever you're
strong enough to carry out
it's yours you know as long as you do
something interesting with it so by
American Dream I suppose that's what I
meant by that now as far as warnings and
danger as well I mean you said it
yourself we also see the American
tendency
well let's don't call it an Americans
it's a human tendency to figure that we
don't need to really be super proactive
in our stewardship of elements of the
geography physical or otherwise that are
meant to preserve our well-being you
know so whether that's all the levees
yeah right well I gotta go home and
watch the football game I won't do the
inspection today or whatever it might be
whatever levels of incompetence or just
bad attention obtained you you know we
see that in New Orleans New Orleans has
suffered from that from climate change
all the way down to just about
everything that you could think about
about about the city and you know
initially I what I started to feel that
lecture was getting a little bit long so
I cut out a long section that I had
quoting from devil sent the rain in a
piece that I wrote after the BP oil
spill do you all remember the Deepwater
Horizon this was 2010 and the pipeline
burst and there were millions or
billions who's counting gallons of oil
being shot out into some of the most
ecologically sensitive waters on the
planet and everybody kept saying oh you
poor guys down there you know first
Katrina now this and I thought what that
was about was people not caring enough
to make sure that there was safety
precautions oh my god regulation god
forbid alright so and I thought well
this is not a new that's not you guys
down there
did have you ever heard of Enron have
you ever heard of worldcom sorry
everybody's probably forgotten about
that
now savings and loan scandal okay you
got to be of a certain age how about the
fact that the entire world economy just
about imploded in 2008 as a result of
the loosening of the Intolerable chains
around the limbs of the beleaguered
banking and you know securities
industries I'm sorry industry you know
those regulations were so 1933 so you
know and we got when we were asking for
but it's an it's and it's a it's a human
problem but we have seen the specific
action I'm sorry specific accent in
which that problem has been articulated
and it's a very American accent and I
would say that New Orleans has shown us
some of the most vivid waking dreams
that could represent that danger that
we've had WorldCom and right all that
stuff didn't offer these searing dreams
to trouble the sleep of the Republic the
New Orleans has but their representative
yeah that worked for you okay everybody
I wanna thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]